What if Superman was in Game of
Thrones? It seems like fans are
going to great lengths to make that
very thing happen–in a way, at least.
Henry Cavill is someone who is well aware of the
Game of Thrones and The Witcher comparisons that
have been floating around the internet for years
now. And, thanks to the fan artist BossLogic,
we can actually see what the star looks like
as a descendant of Valyria, and it's epic.
Back in December 2019, at the
height of the Targaryen talk
and ahead of the The Witcher Season
1, Henry told Entertainment Tonight:
"I think comparisons are always going to be made
and it's fun. It's fine when they're two
ends of a spectrum in a fantasy genre."
Appearing on Jimmy Kimmel Live that same month,
Cavill jokingly told the late-night host,
"I modeled myself after Khaleesi.
I made people call me Khaleesi or
Emilia on set. I want to be Emilia or Khaleesi."
"Call me mother of dragons. I'm fine."
It's no secret that Henry is a huge fan of
fantasy and fiction — whether it be books,
movies, television shows, comics, or video
games. BossLogic and other fan artists have
imagined him in a number of different
franchises and famous forms, including
Wolverine and James Bond. But seeing Cavill as
a Targaryen may truly be the most incredible.
Hide your dragons, folks, because Henry Cavill is
officially here as a member of House Targaryen.
BossLogic shared the awesome fan casting in
late August, through his social media channels.
On the post, the creator joked:
"The hair checks out."
This is in reference to Cavill's similar silver
hairstyle in The Witcher. BossLogic's image of
Cavill was accompanied by a House of the Dragon
banner at the bottom, which debuted in August
2022 and seemingly inspired him. Franchise fans
and viewers have been eating the fan casting up,
with many calling for studio execs to
take notice. One Twitter user wrote:
"Henry Cavill would make a badass Aegon
the Conqueror. Or...Young Jaeharys,
Adult Aegon V, Baelor the Blessed,
Aegon the Unworthy (in his early years).
JUST GIVE CAVILL A COOL TARGARYEN ROLE."
Someone else tweeted,
"What other man would we deem worthy to cast
as rider of Balerion The Black Dread? A dragon
so large it could swallow a fully armored
Knight on Horseback with one snatch of its
Mighty Jaw. Wielding the mighty Valyrian Blade,
Blackfyre. I see no other choice. He's my Aegon."
That all said, what makes the Cavill fan
casting truly epic for Game of Thrones
and House of the Dragon fans is the fact
that Cavill isn't just some George R.R.
Martin novice. For those who aren't aware,
Henry Cavill is someone who is not only a
fan of the Game of Thrones HBO series, but
also the books that inspired it. In fact,
he's even managed to convince others in
Hollywood to read them and was able to pass
on his fandom to at least one of his previous
co-stars — Laurence Fishburne. Conleth Hill,
a Game of Thrones actor and family friend of
Laurence, explained in an interview with Vulture:
"He was about to watch the show, and
Henry Cavill was the one who told him,
'No, no, no, read the books first.’ So he
became a fan of A Song of Ice and Fire,
all the Game of Thrones books. He's read them
all. And then [Fishburne's wife] showed me
a text from Laurence that said, 'Welcome,
master of whisperers and your little birds,
too,' or something like that, which
was very sweet of both of them."
Back in April 2021, Cavill posted a
photo online that showed him playing
a Game of Thrones chess set with his
girlfriend. A Twitter user responded,
"He shouldn't be playing on
a Game of Thrones chess set.
He should have been playing on Game of Thrones."
With House of the Dragon already appearing to be
a major hit for HBO, it's not completely out of
the question for Cavill to appear on the show
one day as a Targaryen. Only time will tell.